[Music]
[Music]
all right should you write a book should
someone or anyone write a book I get
asked questions about launching books
all the time how can I make my book a
best-seller have you written a book no
I'm going to write a book have you
written any books before no why are you
writing a book and we get into this
conversation and ultimately I ask one
question and that is for the period of a
year can you make this your number one
priority for a period of at least a year
can this be your number one if you have
a company that means your business is
number two if you have a family that
means your family is number two can this
be your number-one priority for a year
that's the general litmus test because
if you put out a mediocre book or even a
good book a good enough book which by
the way equals shitty as Brian Grazer
legendary film and TV producer would say
it's more of a liability than a help
okay so a mediocre book is more of a
liability than no book at all you can't
take it back so as Michael Gerber told
me who wrote the e-myth revisited which
is a book that had a huge impact on me
before I launched the 4-hour work what
he said if you're going to write a book
write a [ __ ] book meaning like you're
all in all of your chips are into this
book so how did I know that I should do
four hour workweek right was it that
obvious
was it cleared it was i dying to be a
writer which by the way i don't think is
a necessary checkbox you don't have to
write the book yourself necessarily open
by andre agassi
by the way August II Andre Agassi was
ghostwritten but it was a collaboration
that took a long time and a lot of
Andres time beautifully written but
nonetheless required a lot of focus from
him so you can't have a collaborator but
my I suppose hurdle was it was easier
for me to get out of my head than it was
for me to live with it in my head all
right
it was less painful to put it down than
to have it ricocheting inside my head
and I had all these experiences from
2004 to say end of 2005 where I was
restructuring and reformulating my
entire business to run without me
traveling the world for 18 months
without any set schedule meeting all
these case studies and I was teaching a
class at Princeton twice a year
sometimes in person sometimes remotely
in high tech entrepreneurship whereas
sharing my findings about scaling a
bootstrapped business and that slowly
morphed into lifestyle design how to
create a business or career to allow you
to take advantage of the most valuable
non-renewable resource which is time so
I'm already giving these two to
three-hour classes and I would take
notes and over time because one of the
students said why don't you just write a
book and be done with it as opposed to
teaching a class of 40 students which
was actually a snarky Princeton student
response it wasn't a real suggestion I
don't think nonetheless I had insomnia
for many many many many years and I
couldn't get to sleep because these
chapter ideas would come these stories
would come to mind and I just couldn't
get to sleep without jotting down a
little note on a piece of paper and I
ended up with a huge pile of paper on
lessons learned and so on and I knew
that at least two of my friends and
there were two specific friends in mind
one who is trapped in a decent paying
job where he had no time disliked what
he was doing but he could he could
finally afford that nice car right so he
felt like he was trapped and then I had
a friend who had started his own company
who similarly is making decent money but
felt trapped in a monster of his own
making and I felt these notes would help
them okay
did not want to write a book at that
point actively did not want to write a
book all right but I felt a moral
obligation to share this material
somehow and a few of my friends who were
authors recommended that I explore the
path to publishing it and I made a few
assumptions going into it because keep
in mind I did not want to write a book I
assumed it was going to be extremely
difficult and brutal to write the book
which it was and we're talking repeated
moments of
doubt I should throw in the towel I am
going to have a nervous breakdown
repeatedly okay that is more or less
than the case for every book that I've
written I'm at five now okay the second
assumption was that I was going to
probably hate the book itself which I
did okay and that has been largely true
for every book I've done assume that up
until a year after the book comes out
you're gonna look at it and be
disappointed with what you've produced
given that the third assumption was that
I would write the book and if it even
changed the life of one or two people
that would justify all the pain all the
self-loathing all the loathing of the
book all of the opportunity cost of
putting it together right and that last
but not least it was easier for me less
painful for me to get it out and throw a
Hail Mary and hope for the best then to
keep it inside of me and wonder what if
okay so a lot of different checkboxes
and the book keep in mind for our work
week was rejected by 27 publishers and
then when it was finally printed first
print run was about 10,000 copies you
don't even get national distribution
with that nobody really expected a whole
lot and then with the same amount of
focus that I put into the writing put in
to launch ended up hitting the New York
Times bestseller list and now it's
millions of copies in 40-plus languages
okay but I don't think you get to
millions of copies and 40-plus languages
trying to write a book for the world
that is going to help your business I
just don't think it happens I've never
seen it happen and instead check all the
boxes that I mentioned and I wrote this
book for two friends very specifically
and by personalizing it in that way by
talking to them in a in a very
conversational way we ended up with the
results that we had could have very
easily gone a different direction but if
you can listen to everything I've just
said and you think to yourself I should
write a book then by all means go for it
but for most people this doesn't mean I
am a great writer therefore you need to
be a great writer no I'm
saying it was less painful for me to put
it out than to keep it in my head hey
guys if you're enjoying the tips and
tactics and how-to on this channel or in
the podcast the Tim Ferriss show I made
this for you try to the mentors short
advice from the best in the world this
is the book that I wanted to read so I
went out and I put it together created a
dream list 130 of the best at what they
do people who are icons legends and ask
them all the same questions these are
people in some cases I wanted to reach
out to my whole life ranges from many
many billionaires cofounders of every
company imaginable elite athletes
ranging from surfing to tennis to
powerlifting everything else country
stars actors directors and you can spot
the pattern so some of my friends have
said this is the easiest to read most
useful book that I've put together yet
so check it out tribe of mentors dot-com
you can find sample chapters the whole
list of mentors everything Charbagh
mentors calm